Vìa chọn thạch, phụ vụ vụ nhân dân, người lính trường xa tập trung cao độ để quan sát, dự bảo tình hình,
nghiệm tin yếu sát sòn với đảng được thể hiện trong số báo tương nặp biệt, mừng đảng quan vinh.
Quà, thực hiện tốt như một hả nấu, thì có phần quan trọng vào cái việc bảo vệ,
giúp cái môi trường hà vình của nãy, cũng như nào bảo vệ kê, an toàn cái tối khu vực về những phần công.
Tương chi bộ quan trình liêm giệm vụ quan trực sản trên đấu, mong thiết bị, mong mắt thường,
cán bộ chiến sĩ tiểu đàn để ca một tập trung cao độ để nấm mắt mắt tiêu,
kì thời bảo cáo cấp trên giác quy định chiếc sát, trên thêm lúc địa phía nâng của tục quốc,
nhà dàn là đẹp tượng chắc trong nương dân vinh thôi.
Tình hùng ngang yêu cầu cao, là chất nặng, mừng không thể làm hỏng người liến đặc công hải quân.
Họng dành luyện thường xuyên về các liay bài khó thục tiến có thể diện biến rất nhanh,
phút tập, phải phổ luyện mới thêm gài.
Lưỡng đoàn đã xây dựng kế hoại, tổ chức khốn nửa các phương an, đồng thời,
hẹp đồng chặt trẻ với các lực lượng trong vòng ngoài quân trung, để bảo vệ an toàn các mục tiêu trong thời gian giả đại hội.
Cùng với lựng tập cá tình hùng đối thông, đối hài màu vẻ sức sống tầu,
nhưng ngày này, các tầu trên quân càng càng ràng cũng viên chiếm rất nhiều ngày kỹ thuật,
mối con tầu có hệ số tí thuật cao, sống sàng đi biển tí có lệ,
là cảm kết cao nhất của các tầu mặt nước trên đối hệ đại.
Tầu của một năm đường thực hiện đồng bộ nhiều dài khác trong đó có việc duy tri nhêm tục,
có hiệu quả, chiều sâu, ngảnh kiếp phọt ở đơn vị.
Theo phương trâm, giữ dình tà mới, phục hồi tạo cú, giữ tốt, giữ bàn.
Chên khóc các phương viên đào của tổ phút, bộ lựa hài quân tự tin làm trường trang bị.
Thì tài, hân hoán hoàn yp đó trở thời cơ mới, vẫn hộ mối của đất nước.